voilà on va parler sport maintenant dans
le 7-8 week-end avec nos deux invités
joël savary bonjour bonjour bon trader
de kick boxing et samir ou bonsoir
bonjour donc cette annonce à sa défense
voilà sept ans la tôt avec nous
aujourd'hui c'est pour nous parler d'un
stage à la fois de kick boxing et la foi
de self défense qui aura lieu dimanche à
bonnart 6 allons d'abord j'ai envie de
dire quel est le lien entre ces deux
disciplines
joël
le lien est réparé cet ami il ya un vide
en france depuis de nombreuses années et
faut savoir que le kickboxing donc sport
de percussion
le lien qui va se faire avec sami donc
c'est la défense ça va être une approche
plus tôt
complémentaires c'est à dire que la boxe
on va apprendre à donner un coup on va
apprendre à donner des coups de pied des
coups de poing et en self défense on va
apprendre à neutraliser c'est un bon
concept qui fait que techniquement c'est
complémentaire
ces compléments est trompeur expliquer
ce qu'est le kickboxing pour ceux qui me
connaissent savent c'est la boxe mois
pourtant j'étais venu l'année dernière
alors c'est de la boxe pieds poings et
points voilà c'est la boxe pieds-poings
où on va pouvoir se lâcher et puis
donner des coups toujours avec des
protections donc en protection on a le
casque on al akouki on a des
protège-tibias élégant et le self
défense c'est plus du coup la vie
pratique il de celle de tunis et
aujourd'hui on est dans un quotidien qui
est de plus en plus hostile c'est de se
dire comment je peux agir comme enjeu
pour une défense me défendre face à des
situations qui défauts peuvent peuvent
paraître dangereuse où vous je me sens
en difficulté en en insécurité
alors justement qui s'adresse ce stage
mixte celle défense kick boxing qui 0
pendant deux heures dimanche qui
s'adresse est-ce que s'adresse à des
sportifs ou est-ce que cette adresse des
hommes des femmes du quotidien ça
s'adresse à toutes populations
confondues hommes femmes enfants
également donc enfin on va avoir des
enfants qui
mon plus jeune va avoir dix ans e
voilà ça c'est un stage d'initiation
donc on va apprendre à se déplacer
on va apprendre à donner des coups et on
va également apprendre à neutraliser
comment réagir en fait en cas de
difficultés c'est là où je reprends ce
que je le disais tout à l'heure c'est de
se dire voilà j'apprends à bouger
j'apprends à mettre un coup de poing
mettre un coup de pied et ça me permet
d'avoir aussi plus de facilité à
assimiler comment réagir quand j'ai un
coup de poing qui arrive ou quand j'ai
un coup de pied qui arrive alors venu
vous dire c'est facile en fait si vous
nous montrez comment faire pour réagir
mais quand on se trouve dans la
situation par exemple on est en train de
se faire voler son portable dans la
panique
comment on fait pour pas oublier juste
avant le geste ferait appel
c'est là aussi où dans la proche qu'on
peut avoir sur ce stage on va avoir
aussi une approche psychologique
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui une
agression si on l'a pas vécu on sait pas
ce que ça peut provoquer dans le corps
on ne sait pas comment on peut réagir et
puis quoi qu'il arrive même quand on est
prêts on n'est jamais réellement prêts à
une agression en revanche le fait
d'avoir déjà réfléchi à ce que pouvait
provoquer une agression d'avoir échangé
avec des personnes qui ont pu vivre ça
ou qui ont l'habitude d'être confrontés
à des six que ça provoque une agression
sa base aucune paralysie
ça peut provoquer une paralysie on est
là on était à l'elysée on sait pas
comment faire
oui une cote comme senti on est une
femme ou ray se met à crier voilà c'est
ça c'est un bon réflexe
ah oui on me l'avait d'ailleurs c'est
vraiment dissuader sait comment réagir
c'est pas faire des choses compliquées
mais des choses qui vont être efficace
qui vont nous permettre de nous en
sortir rapidement justement donc des
choses pas compliquée qu'elle conseille
on peut donner là j'ai dit en
plaisantant on se met à crier parce
qu'on est une femme on a peur on crime
pour faire peur pour ça peut certes et
ça peut être crié on est une femme on a
ça qu'on a un coup de sac
ça peut être peint ces quelques pas
pourquoi parce que quand on se fait
pincer
on va avoir le réflexe de réagir souvent
les agresseurs sont des hommes ils ont
des parties génitales donc c'est aussi
d'avoir le réflexe d'un petit capital
voilà c'est avec les doigts dans les
yeux qui vont provoquer n'importe quel
être humain prend doigt dans l'oeil le
réflexe qui lassé de se mettre en
arrière de faire mes yeux c'est tout
plein de petits réflexes comme ça qui
peuvent servir à une femme à un homme
tout comme moi
un aux deux ânes adolescents ou un
enfant c'est vraiment réussira à se dire
voilà je viens ce stage je vais pas
forcément être des gestes assez simple
en fait c'est c'est intuitif cdu
effectivement comme vous dites dures et
de l'ex pourrait être amenée à se
dégager avec véhémence et on met le
doigt dans l'oeil de son agresseur a
priori il va se dégager il va pas se
gêner cap et du coup ce stage ans
rejoint sur cette défense stage idée il
s'adresse aux hommes aux femmes
est ce que dans le nombre d'inscrits que
vous avez dimanche plus de femmes que
d'hommes où il ya aussi des hommes qui
ont envie de savoir comment on peut se
protéger qui se sent on a aussi des
hommes qui veulent savoir comment se
protéger on a des hommes qui veulent
aussi découvrir que ce soit la
discipline du kickboxing que ce soit la
self défense
c'est vraiment on cherche à regrouper et
à sensibiliser un maximum de personnes
géraient leur lors de ce stage
pour pour aussi que cette discipline
soit connue et puis qu'on arrive
j'irai a commencé à toucher un maximum
de personnes à donner les bons réflexes
à sensibiliser aussi face à une une vie
qui est de plus en plus compliqué je
dirais des fois on tombe on est dans une
société où on a forcément envie de se
rassurer par tous les moyens donc
apprendre le kickboxing ma petite que la
self défense même si on va pas sortir
champion du monde à la sortie du stage
va repartir avec quelque chose va mais
dites moi monsieur est ce que le sourire
et la bonne humeur ou en semoule ironie
ça peut aussi être une arme de défense
non la grève si vous arrivez c'est des
fois des arbres à ce match tout à fait
essentiel pour vous parler par
l'entretien
vous avez aussi des adolescents qui
aimait participer à ces stages parce que
il ya aussi une inquiétude sur certains
adolescents qui peuvent être ennuyé au
collège première agression c'est le
portable la tablette manquent eux
j'ai quelques adolescents qui ont
entendu parler du stage et qui vont
venir découvrir donc
ce stage avec le portable de nos jours
et vous pourriez faire une session
spécifiquement pour pour ce jeune public
va disons qu'à la suite de ce stage on
va on va travailler sur le concept avec
sa famille puis oui je reviendrai parler
de deuxième stage prochaine parker à la
même question à poser est justement la
suite alors la ccin stage est ouvert à
tout public qui dure deux heures dans
une farce seulement deux heures c'est à
cet âge à l'initiation séparer stage où
ça donne envie 2
et alors si on a envie de continuer on
fait quoi voilà sa vie alors c'est là où
le but aussi de ce stage c'est avec joie
nous on est en train de solliciter
certaines certaines municipalités pour
réussir à la rentrée prochaine à faire
cette discipline qu'on appelle un peu le
boxing défense c'est un peu nouveau
c'est un concept pourquoi parce qu'on se
rend compte que aujourd'hui on a du mal
à avoir des personnes qui vont faire du
kickboxing la box ou un sport de contact
et qui font aussi en parallèle un sport
de enfin de la self défense
donc notre but c'est de réussir à
jumeler les deux bas toujours dans cet
esprit de commando demande de complément
complémentarité pour justement va
réussir à satisfaire des personnes qui
n'ont jamais mis de gants et des
personnes qui veulent aussi se défendre
pourquoi parce que la selle défense va
être un peu moins physique que le
kickboxing que joël peu l'enseigné et ça
fait une bonne complémentarité dans le
sens où on va avoir un aspect physique
un aspect sport où je veux vraiment
avoir la sueur et puis de la fatigue à
la fin de l'entraînement et la partie
self où on va répéter beaucoup de
mouvements beaucoup de mouvements pour
avoir des réflexes et ne pas avoir
besoin de gerland teasé que c'est des
mouvements simples c'est de la mallette
certains mouvements c'est donc le moment
accessible
c'est tout le monde a envie de penser
par exemple à une personne qui à 60 ou
70 ans je sais pas si on va la prendre
c'est leur point musclée après
l'avantagent l'avantagent de la self
défense c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
un c'est pas codifié ça veut dire qu'on
peut adapter une manière de se défendre
à tout le monde on peut avoir le soit
l'âge quel que soit le choix si vous
êtes grand baraqué
omnitech lui et voilà tout à fait le but
c'est de se chercher à s'adapter aussi à
l'élève qu'on peut avoir en face de nous
de se dire mais à toi t'es peut-être
qu'il va être plus maigre aucun autre
plus petit par contre il va avoir
d'autres solutions qui vont être plus
avantageuses que d'autres là le stage a
lieu au cosec à bollaert c'est que les
dossiers mais s'avère que vos à bois
d'arcy pourrait voir poyer continuer à
faire ce que vous souhaitez à bois
d'arcy ouvrait vraiment vous appelez ça
un appel aux dons lancé dedans que le
camion à l'origine 50 ans autre question
le coût de ce stage combien ça coûte
pour ceux qui veulent par tous alors en
préinscription 6,25 euros et sur place 6
30 euros 30 euros sachant qu'en prince
cription normalement il ya une petite
adresse e-mail voilà tout et ses
châteaux chine c'est magique ce cher
sinon attention à qui enrichissent n'ai
pas dit je souris en régime on a une
spécialité cette défense très bien donc
5 haro sur le plateau caillou donc je
rappelle ce stage de kick boxing et de
self défense qui a lieu au cosec à la
boîte arcis donc c'est dimanche entre
14h et 16h vous avez à peu près une
trentaine d'inscrits c'est ça il donc
encore des places pour sont engagement
complètement ce accueillir jusqu'à 100
personnes dont un bon alors ça va
j'attends les mène merci à vous